um you know I think Google deserve some
credit for doing a little bit when it
comes to experimenting with public
versus private entries and calendars and
trying to make that to open up the
calendar to more public consumption but
they didn't really take it very far and
so it leaves so the challenge up to
people like us to figure out what can we
do to innovate around how people use
their calendars I mean we often call
ourselves sort of a social calendar even
though we're not looking to replace in
any way you know google calendar or your
outlook it's a different sort of
experience that I want to provide for
people but there's there's natural tions
the calendars that you you already use
so when we started off everything was
public on plancast and before we
introduced any kind of privacy settings
we definitely had a lot more feedback
from our users from the segment and it
was a minority segment that it wanted to
have a greater control over just to gets
their plans just said that basic I want
my account to be only accessible by the
people that I pre-approve since then
since we introduced that functionality
we don't actually hear a lot from our
users about hey I wish you know things
were just generally more private there's
feature requests around you know certain
plans when people post them they want
those to be private but those sort of
activities just aren't on the site yet
because people opt into not sharing back
stuff yet so it's not as though we feel
as though our users are putting stuff
out there right now that they're
actively concerned will come back and
hurt them we're surprised by on a
percentage basis the number of people
who either decided to keep their plans
open or decide to walk them down yeah I
mean there's a it's a very small
percentage of people who have locked
down our account very small percentage i
mean i can tell you on tunngle side when
we went through this joint index or not
you want to profile to be open to the
world
about 85 to 90 percent it's a young
school yeah yeah I think there's a lot
to be said for people's understanding
that they sort of live two lives there's
the life stuff they're going to share
publicly in this stuff they're going to
keep private and I think if you frame
your service as a by default public sort
of thing people going to get that and
they're going to interact with it as
such and they're not going to complain
bitterly about not being it will share
certain private things they're more like
likely just to request functionality but
that will allow them to do that so it's
not really a problem per se it's just if
if you want to somehow capture that sort
of more private activity you have to
think of ways to to allow for it so we
don't really view it as a problem we
just viewed as a sort of strategic data
issue how do we you know what's the pros
and cons of getting more granular
controls and we don't want to make it
more complicated than it has to be which
is probably why we kept it open the
public to start with